we got here
I think that's Cod that's interesting
isn't it because then olive
they're raisins there's no peppers and
there's no capers
it's a Trey's description this year she
says it says it's with capers and olives
but I see a small amount of sultanas
change the men actually changed the dish
yeah but it's the old dish on here I'm
allergic to those I can't eat sultanas
you want me today no I can't it's been
on if it's being on the plate I can't I
can't have it yeah we working on that
one it's not just offered to take this
on Tom's off and bring back the plate
for Sid Bream on it now we've been
chatting and looking at it and stuff
it's cold now Cod on the menu so with
capers and peppers arrives with raisins
what happened there went on not that in
Dominion not changing the menu disturb
him I mean how uninterested was that
waiter he's like a zombie I feel quite
ashamed when I've seen this shot of
attitude in the service cause I got a
cool hip
amazing restaurant there you're sat on
something potentially brilliant and if
someone wants to turn out to work and
talk like that to customers getting
washing [ __ ] dishes
I feel your gossip gloss of red wine
which would you advise no I only have
this one the romantic yep
thank you just a glass
see where's my where's my glass that red
line that's Facebook on the computer
check it out his mates and still my
secret diners without the wine excuse me
the I order the glass of red wine oh
yeah
so I I hope I didn't interrupt you know
opening
what kind of impression does that serve
to customers when a waiters sat there on
a computer I think it just don't afford
it with a head for the quality of the
food and the ability of the chef it's
good value where it's omni stops being
good value is when you have service like
the service that we've seen today it is
such a shame to see fantastic food let
down by extremely poor service all their
hard work but the way these guys put it
negative gone just humbly drain by bad
attitude and just hurry faith you've got
every right to feel let down but it's
not over and done with it's still very
strong in this competition and you need
to bounce back
not to do there was no problem with the
food except wrong with the service so I
feel personally responsible for that I
just feel you know that we fail
disappointed so we need to work together
as a team and we will make sure this
doesn't happen ever again